130 مصابا في حصيله غير نهائيه بعد زلزلين
فيها تايطلعنا على التطورات والمعلومات
حيث انت
بالفعل جلال الاصابات هنا معظمها من سقوط
حجاره على على المدنيين في الشارع ونتيجه
كذلك انهيار جدران منازل او شرف منازل على
في الشارع وبالتالي على المدنيين لكن
هنالك اصابات اخرى نتيجه حالات من الهلع
والخوف نتيجه ان اناسا رموا بانفسهم من
الابنيه السكنيه من شروفات منازلهم ما
تعرضوا الى كسور وبالاضافه الى حالاتنا
الاغماء
فهذا العدد من الجرحى معظمهم نتيجه حالات
كسور ونتيجه حالات اغماء وصلت الى
المستشفيات وفق الدفاع المدني فان هنالك
130 جريحا معظمهم كسور وحالات اغماء
بالاضافه الى جرحى سقطت عليهم حجاره جدران
شرف منازل هذا في مناطق شمال الغربي سوريا
النظام السوري كذلك وسائل الاعلام النظام
السوري تتحدث ان هنالك 120 حاله اصابه نفس
الحالات تماما نتيجه حالات الهلع والخوف
واناس رموا بانفسهم من الابنيه السكنيه
الدفاع المدني يؤكد بان هنالك ابنيه سكنيه
قد انهارت في جنديرس وفي مناطق اخرى في
ريف حلب لكن يقول انه لا اصابات او لا
حالات وفيات حتى الان نتيجه ان هذه
الابنيه التي انهارت في جنديرس هي ابنيه
لم يكن فيها سكان جنديرس 85 في المئه من
مبانيها بالاصل كانت مدمره اما بشكل كامل
او بشكل جزئي الابنيه الباقيه ايله للسقوط
بالتالي المدينه بنسبه كبيره جدا كانت قد
نزح السكان منها هذا ما يفسر انه ليس
هنالك اصابات نتيجه انهيار المباني
السكنيه في جنديرس لكن الان المشهد
الرئيسي هو حاله الهلع هو الخوف الكبير
لدى السكان حاله نزوح جماعيه من المدن
باتجاه
مخيمات باتجاه
قوارع او قارعات الطرق الى حافتي الطرق في
شمال غربي سوريا خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه التي نشعر بها هنا ايضا ما بين
الفينه الاخرى نتحدث عن اكبر هزه ربما
حصلت بعد الزلزلين الاوليين في سته شباط
الان
هذين الزلزلين اللذين حصل قبل قليل هما
الاكبر على مدى الايام الماضيه بالتالي
الناس عندها حاله كبيره من الهلع وموجودون
في مخيمات في حدائق عامه في ساحات من يملك
سياره فهو في سيارته وسط تحذيرات من
الدفاع المدني ان لا يعود الناس الى الاب
الى مبانيهم خصوصا التي تلك التي هي قد
اصابها تصدعات وتشققات